all right given Friday's kick in the gut
to the Trump base you know when the
president decided to sign not veto that
1.3 trillion dollar omnibus ball well
the phrase Trump wins on principle might
seem a little bit odd to say the least
but bear with me
amid the disappointment that a lot of
you are rightly feeling myself included
given the bait and switch on the border
wall and effective Planned Parenthood
gets full funding I want to tell you
tonight there are victories on the
horizon especially involving one
critical area that is woefully under
covered by the American media in which
the president remember relentlessly
pressed on the campaign trail on trade
we are going to end the international
abuse our massive chronic trade deficits
are destroying the middle class and
shifting money away from workers to
large corporations who have no borders
it's one of the big reasons why he got
elected and I'll tell you Trump's team
they've been busily renegotiating trade
deals and knocking down market barriers
that have been killing off American
manufacturing and hurting our workers
and the good fruits of this work are now
emerging
remember those want serious TV networks
like CNN and CBS well our trade policy
for them doesn't merit as much airtime
as porn stars and alleged paramours but
our trade relationship with the rest of
the world has lasting impact on the
lives of most Americans and their
families Trump has been pretty wily on
trade overall and he's made provocative
and bold moves he's talked tough he's
threatened tariffs and it almost every
turn the globalist predicted total
disaster and the US president said he
says he's going to impose tariffs on
steel and aluminum imports this is
basically a byword for while I might
start a trade war there are real
consequences to these statements and
actions and he doesn't seem to
appreciate this is a toxic mix that
we're in right now and if the president
pushes ahead with this
could it's not far too far a reach to
say could this be the thing that pushes
the world into a period of a very
considerable instability oh my god
how do these people still work in
television after I don't get it well
once again the so called experts I say
that all the time the so-called experts
were wrong
Trump's tariffs on Chinese steel and
aluminum and last week's proposal to
raise sixty billion dollars worth of
tariffs on other Chinese goods have
brought Beijing to the negotiating table
and they're getting results today's
China choice chase Chinese economic
minister announced that they're
continuing talks with the Trump
administration but they already
committed to a lot like this easing us
access to the China's Chinese market
treating domestic and foreign firms
equally increasing US semiconductor
imports that's big and they will no
longer require US firms to hand over
intellectual property to their Chinese
partners in exchange for operating in
the country the Financial Times is
reporting that the Trump team is also
making headway in lowering Chinese
tariffs on American cars and that
they're going to gain access to the
Chinese financial sector well folks
since we have a three hundred and
seventy five billion dollar trade
deficit with China this is all really
good news on trade let's remember the
president has stood on principle he
stuck to his guns and he completely
altered the dynamic for the better and
it's not only in China the White House
says that a new NAFTA deal is in the
offing and we should note that Jared
Kushner is working hard on this behind
the scenes then today we learned that
Trump's tariff talk had brought back
Korea to the trade bargaining table as
well I mean think about this less than
three months after he was elected
president Trump made it crystal clear
what he thought of that
Korean US free trade deal we have a
horrible trade deal with Korea but now
even before we do something with that
because we're negotiating the
deal with career and we'll either
negotiate a fair deal or we're going to
terminate the deal well of course that
horrified the globalists but it got
South Korea's attention big leak for
months now Trump's team has been
plugging away haven't heard a lot about
it at a total renegotiation of that
agreement now the deal was approved in
2012 and it used NAFTA as its framework
so it's not really all that shocking
that it turned out to be a complete
nightmare in the first five years since
it went into effect our trade deficit
with Korea increased for all but one
month 59 out of 60 months our auto
sector was hardest hit but others were
as well last year Korea shipped more
than 16 billion dollars worth of
passenger cars here but we sent only 1.5
billion dollars worth of vehicles over
there yet today Korea announced it had
made significant concessions to benefit
us
automakers while also there capping the
amount of Korean steel that can flood
into our markets for that they're gonna
get a partial exemption from Trump's
tariffs this is terrific news for
American industry and it's also great
news for our national security as well
because it's removing obstacles to
cooperating and dealing with the North
Korean threat it also shows us how Trump
uses leverage you gotta use the leverage
where you have it tariffs are not a
four-letter word most presidents have
used them selectively but they've used
them but of course the fake news well
they prefer to ignore these substantive
issues you know the ones that really
matter and all the progress that Trump
is made for millions of Americans on
these issues citizens by the way who've
seen their way of life their standard of
living destroyed over the past two
decades during the period of what
unchecked trade abuses you know people
who work for companies like dusty
Stevens my father worked at that smelter
for 40 years he retired hourly so
another guy keep his job
my brother he was laid off during the
downtime he didn't come back to work so
this is directly affected our family not
only ours but every year there's over
300 other families that were affected by
this downturn and now the Trump
administration is giving it back to us
speaking for steel companies aluminum
companies representing a lot of people
those are the Forgotten Americans that's
who turned out to vote for president
Trump in 2016 they need him to keep
challenging the Washington corrupt ik
rats in changing policies that just do
not work while the left-wing resistance
is marinating and things like protest
propaganda and porn stars the Trump
administration should stick to first
principles now it's a shame they blew it
on the Omnibus but they are killing it
on trade and so we soldier on and that's
the angle